popular radio host Charlemagne the God
giving the Democratic party a very Grim
forecast on their 2024 prospects saying
it's sad that the party cannot find
anyone better than Biden
I think that's more indicative of what
you know Democrats aren't doing and for
me I just don't I don't I don't see the
bench that the Democrats have like I
don't I personally don't see the person
that they could put up in 2024 that
could like really Galvanize and energize
people I mean the fact that Biden is
still their safest bet I think that's
sad too
Charlemagne also thinks Kamala Harris is
a total loser adding that he does not
believe the vice president is a viable
candidate and would lose against some
top Republicans if she is the party's
nominee and liberal Outlets slate.com
thinks Joe should straight up abandon
his number two quote if Biden runs again
he should pick a new VP Kamala Harris
had her chance the Democrats need
something different okay so let's get
rid of the easy question here Brian
Kamala she's gone right little surprise
him because she went and did his show
remember she pretended to like uh uh
who's yeah
yeah and when evidently they didn't have
any music out at that time and she lied
right so she lied about that and so he
picked up on that and he does not for
he's also not for people to judge goes
smart guy but he doesn't think the
American people are ready to vote for
him so he says there without any options
he also said about when it comes down to
Trump he says the problem with Trump is
all the investigations and things around
him he thinks it'll be a big Showdown
and that DeSantis will win I don't know
where he gets the statement when he says
people were sleeping at Ron DeSantis
everybody's talking about Ron DeSantis
no one's sleeping on him yeah and you
know um Dana that Charlemagne tha God
says he believes uh that that both Biden
and Kamala would lose to Trump or
DeSantis I mean he hasn't given up on
Trump totally so is what's interesting
is that he is like somebody in the
Democratic party like Ben Jones or Bill
Maher or James Carville they say really
smart things really wise things and then
they are wholly ignored by the
Democratic party and then at the end of
an election they're like wow we should
have really listened to those guys I
think that's a very sick burn of the
vice president and I imagine that Kamala
Harris will announce a full departing of
all staff by Saturday and a new team by
Monday that will be the seventh
rendition to see if she can try to
figure it out again it's like it's what
he's saying and he knows her he's
talking many times that she's not the
one and so now I kind of wonder if in a
way the midterms will end up being a
little bit of a long-term problem for
the Democratic party because now
President Biden has a little bit of wind
at his back and he's thinking he's going
to run again and I bet this week and
he'll be like you know what I feel
pretty good I'm 80. I just did better
than I thought I would do in in the
midterms I'm going to run again instead
of giving the Democrats a reason to say
goodbye let's move on now the
Republicans get a lot of talk about
being in disarray and there is that yes
of course but the mirror image is quite
interesting on the Democratic side and
their bench is so weak that is the real
soft underbelly of their problems you
know Harold four Congressional Democrats
anonymously said that half of the
Democrats in Congress would not support
Biden you think that's true I don't know
I mean you know I was in Congress and
people spoken to Adam said they
generally had some sources for doing
that uh at least had some fillers out in
the party there's no doubt that four
weeks ago there was a wide feeling or
growing feeling amongst at least the
Democrat kind of elite class that but
Biden shouldn't should seriously
consider not running and I think that
group thought that the midterms would
turn out poorly the midterms didn't turn
on as poorly as some thought now there's
a and as a result there's some who think
that maybe Vice President Biden and vice
president Harris may decide that they've
had a good run here maybe they ought to
open a door for someone else as Nancy
Pelosi has done the challenge is what's
been said that bench is not readily
apparent look I'm always question I
question anybody who has God in their
name who's not a God but I think the guy
makes them he's entitled to his opinion
and he has an interesting interesting
opinion he probably has credibility on
some of this because of the things that
you I think Brian you and you and uh you
and Dana shared he was supportive of
Vice President Harris and said that it
was one of the best things that
President Biden did was choosing her now
he's being critical I think again this
is one of the lessons democrats should
take from this we should not believe for
any reason for any moment that we should
not be serious about crime in the Border
we should not believe for any moment
that we should not be serious about
energy and should not be not be deluded
to believing we should not think more
creatively about how to invigorate Main
Street Americans small business in
America uh and as a result that may mean
we need new Personnel at this moment
though as much as it may be Miracle we
have these challenges Dana Democrats
Biden feels better about his chances
than Trump DeSantis Haley Scott and we
can go down the list Pompeo I heard
something Pompeo said today about Randy
Weingarten it was unbelievable to me but
look we're going to get this we'll get a
chance to see this thing play out Jesse
wrap it up well he does have things
going for him he just kept the Senate
and he can raise a lot of money and he's
well liked by Corporate America yeah my
president I'm talking about President
Biden and he's an incumbent which is
hard to beat but on the other hand his
legislative agenda is totally shot now
that the Republicans have the house
they're going to crank up investigations
and expose his family finances and
Corruption and people have never seen
that before and he may say you know he
matches up well against Trump but we
don't have covet this time in 2024 and
he does not match up well against Ron
DeSantis so it's whether or not Joe
Biden is going to be able to campaign
because of his health and if he does
campaign how does he do that and also
stay home in Delaware you have to
actually go to swing States when you're
running a general people don't show up
right so is it going to be the pro-biden
voter that comes out or is it the
anti-trump really that's the thing but I
wanted to discuss King Charlemagne where
the God took the name from this guy has
an amazing family tree are you ready his
children pep in the Hunchback Charles
the younger siblings
carlamon Gisela parents pep in the short
grandchild Charles the bald took over
all of Europe Holy Roman Empire that's
where he got it from thank you Jesse
you're welcome ahead the White House is
ready to rumble over Hunter Biden
investigations as one media Outlet
finally admits the lamp I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now